a las vegas family getting a big
surprise when they discover a mountain
lion right in their backyard metro
police had been chasing the wild animal
hours before until they finally
euthanized it christian casares joined
us live near el capitan and saddle
avenue in spring mountain with how all
of this went down christian
hey guys well it actually took several
hours for metro police and envy wildlife
to capture and euthanize the mountain
lion now everything wrapped up here
inside this home's backyard the family
giving us permission to be out here to
show you guys exactly what happened and
they tell me that they saw the wild
animal jump from that fence into their
property that is when their dog began to
bark at the wild animal alerting the
family and it scared the cat up this
tree and that is when officials were
able to control the situation
it was a rush
the ortiz family still shaken up after
discovering a mountain lion in their
backyard monday morning their pit bull
alerting them of the danger minutes
before metro police arrived i went and
put the dogs inside and they were like
go inside guys go inside and i was like
okay so we put our dogs inside we all go
inside and then all of a sudden we hear
a gunshot and i'm like oh my gosh the
family capturing this video from inside
their home after they say two shots were
fired that's when envy wildlife captured
and euthanized the wild animal
but the chase began earlier in the
morning when police were called about
the sighting near el capitan and twain
when the animal was found inside a
backyard in a different property some
neighbors concerned about what was
happening after police advised them to
stay indoors when the animal escaped
their perimeter just kind of crazy i
wonder how it got way over here
you know without being seen a red flag
for this grandmother who says she will
keep a better watch for her family's
safety you know why because she rides
her bike she'll come outside by herself
and ride the bike up and down the street
so now i'm like oh god no
never again
back out here live i can tell you that
metro police and envy wildlife worked
side by side on this issue and and guys
it really is an unusual sighting for
this wild animal to be in this part of
the valley according to several
neighbors that we uh spoke to again no
official word as to why officials had to
euthanize this mountain lion christian
gossip is live local now